sous le ciel gris de Sibérie le chagrin
d'une famille est de tout un village
il s'appelait Nikita Perline il est mort
à quelques jours de son 32e anniversaire
sur le front quelque part en Ukraine il
n'avait jamais combattu auparavant son
histoire c'est celle de centaines de
réservistes russes mobilisés en urgence
fin septembre sur ordre du président
Poutine
il a été mobilisé le 29 septembre 5
jours plus tard il était temps d'Ukraine
nous sommes très en colère il n'y a
aucune préparation pour ces hommes ils
ont été envoyés en Ukraine comme de la
chair à canon
la colère dans cette pleine lointaine de
Sibérie plongée bien malgré elle dans la
guerre 4 autres jeunes réservistes du
même district sont morts en même temps
que Nikita Perline nous disons adieu
aujourd'hui à Nikita
ses proches critiques ouvertement les
conditions de sa mobilisation et les
cafouillages du commandement dans
l'annonce de son décès autant quelques
jours après son arrivée en Ukraine on a
reçu son avis de décès puis un officier
est venu nous dire que c'était une
erreur et qu'il ne savait pas où il
était une semaine après l'armée a appelé
sa femme pour lui dire qu'en fait
c'était bien lui qui était mort
un préparation encadrement défaillant
pénurie d'équipements en réponse aux
critiques le ministère russe de la
Défense publie ses images d'entraînement
de jeunes recrues près de
Saint-Pétersbourg selon le Kremlin
depuis fin septembre 200000 réservistes
ont renforcé les rangs de l'armée russe
pour faire face à la contre-offensive
ukrainienne dans l'Est et le Sud du pays